c'est vraiment la fin d'émission
c'est vraiment le dernier jour pas grave
je suis désolé a plus que toi en août là
oui on encore le canapé ne sais pas non
mais j'y mettais des matières y bat
prends ta caméra le site initial à la
fnaca oui robert copin on va s'asseoir
europe 1
oya mais qu'en plus ils ont juste eu des
passages et c'est donc tout est fini et
quand on s'en va en général en polynésie
qui est quand même un des endroits où
les gens le plus moral avec les antilles
par nos îles d'un buisson où on parle
encore cette belle langue que le
français
ce qui bien tahiti c'est qu'au lieu de
dire au revoir aux gens qui s'en vont il
me la tend les verts les verts les verts
ont redit qu'ils disent merci
la chanson d'adieu de tahiti cayla plus
à mon avis la plus terrible est la plus
dure quand tu pars des usines soit
antoine est bien d'accord avec joie mais
aussi noël sur des coureurs
c'est le marron mais en vous c'est très
beau et très joli on fait juste un petit
coup comme ça c'est aussi important que
le fera du foulard à de madras bon pied
c'est traditionnel
et présenter les lacets c'est le mal au
dos à barres et
whaou 3 rue les mains
détail y est
ma roue avant et tiaret haïti et
malo
oa
et
malo à va
ah ouais
le foulard oui c'est aussi aussi comme
ça mais c'est une chose de plus con qui
sont les plus belles quand on est
tristes vieux foulard à vienne
deux mois
ligue a pâti et à sel
c'est pour toujours
j'ai gardé et
à la barre du régime d'amour de new york
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu